في دنيترو وسط اوكرانيا يعمل هذا المستشفى
في الظلام منذ تعرض المدينه للقذف الروسيه
الاسبوع الماضي خلال زيارته لاوكرانيا جدد
المدير الاقليمي لاوروبا في منظمه الصحه
العالميه دعمه للعاملين في المجال الطبي
الزمالك
على مرافق الرعايه الصحيه حتى الان سجلت
منظمه الصحه العالميه اكثر من 700 هجوم
على المرافق الصحيه هذا انتهاك واضح جدا
للقانون الدولي الاربعاء قتل رضيع بعد
يومين فقط على ولادته اثر قصف قسم الولاده
في مستشفى
الجريمه ضد الانسانيه
روسكم يعني
حازم من المجتمع الدولي ضد الارهاب الروسي
المستعيدي حاليا اننا ننتظر ردا من
شركائنا
ضربت الروسيه في الايام الاخيره ادت الى
سقوط العديد من القتل وانقطاع واسع
للكهرباء والمياه خاصه في العاصمه كيف
استراتيجيه دقيقه من جانب بوتين تقول
واشنطن سيمبا
الاوكرانيه
الشعب الاوكراني لمعانات كبيره
عن تقديم مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا
400 مليون دولار